?
>> PRISCILLA ALVAREZ, REPORTING
LIVE FROM MIAMI, FLORIDA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S DIG DEEPER, NOW, WITH
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN
VICTORIA SPARKS.
SHE IS CURRENTLY SERVING ON THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON IMMIGRATION
AND CITIZENSHIP.
CONGRESSWOMAN, WE ARE GRATEFUL
THAT YOU ARE SHARING PART OF
YOUR WEEKEND WITH US.
JUST, QUICKLY, I WANT TO GET
YOUR RESPONSE TO WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING UNFOLD IN PLACES LIKE
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
>> WELL, LET ME TELL YOU, I
ACTUALLY WENT THERE THREE TIMES
LAST YEAR.
AND THE SITUATION IS VERY
DANGEROUS AT THE BORDER, IT IS
VERY DANGEROUS, I'LL BE HONEST
WITH YOU, DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING
POLITICS WITH PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND, THESE POOR PEOPLE BECOME
HOSTAGES TO CARTELS, YOU KNOW,
THEY HAVE BEEN SOLD TO SLAVERY.
IT IS PRETTY BAD.
AND, I THINK CARTELS ARE MAKING
A LOT OF MONEY ON THE BORDER.
IT IS A VERY SERIOUS SITUATION.
SO, WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
CRISIS, IT IS A SERIOUS CRISIS.
IT IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS.
I HOPE WHEN WE STOP PLAYING
POLITICS AND LOOK AT IT ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS.
I ASKED MY COLLEAGUES TO
ACTUALLY JUST THINK ABOUT THAT,
LET'S JUST FIND A SOLUTION TO
OUR ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, BUT,
ALSO SECURE THIS BORDER.
THIS IS BAD FOR THE PEOPLE, THE
POOR PEOPLE THAT COME INTO THIS
COUNTRY, DESPERATE PEOPLE.
IT'S BAD FOR OUR COUNTRY, IT IS
BAD FOR EVERYONE AND NO ONE HAS
WANTED TO DO ANYTHING AND IT IS
UNFORTUNATE.
I AM GLAD WE ARE AT LEAST
TALKING ABOUT IT.
HOPEFULLY WE CONTINUE DOING
THAT.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, I WANT TO
PLAY SOME SOUND FOR YOU FROM
RACHEL --
SHE IS AN IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING SOME OF THE FOLKS
THAT WERE SENT TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> THEY WERE LIED TO, AGAIN,
AND AGAIN.
AND, FRAUDULENTLY INDUCED TO
BOARD THE PLANE'S.
THEY WERE TOLD THERE WAS A
SURPRISE PRESENT FOR THEM.
AND THAT THERE WOULD BE JOBS
AND HOUSING AWAITING FOR THEM
WHEN THEY ARRIVED.
THIS WAS OBVIOUSLY A STATISTIC
LIE.
NOT ONLY DID THOSE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS STUNT KNOW THAT THERE
WAS NO HOUSING AND NO
EMPLOYMENT AWAITING THE
MIGRANTS, THEY ALSO, VERY
INTENTIONALLY, CHOSE NOT TO
CALL AHEAD.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, IT SOUNDS
LIKE SOME OF THESE MIGRANTS
WERE LIED TO ABOUT WHERE THEY
WERE GOING, AND WHEN THEY WERE
PUT ON PLANES HEADED TO THAT
ISLAND.
YOU AND I HAVE SOMETHING IN
COMMON.
YOU WERE BORN IN THE FORMER
U.S. AS OUR, YOU ARE AN
IMMIGRANT.
JUST LIKE I DID WHEN I WAS A
CHILD WHO CAME TO THIS COUNTRY,
FLAYING TOTALITARIAN MARXISM.
THESE VENEZUELAN MIGRANTS ARE
TRYING TO GET AWAY FROM A VERY
SIMILAR KIND OF OPPRESSION.
DO YOU THINK THE WAY THEY ARE
BEING TREATED AS APPROPRIATE?
IS THIS HOW YOU WOULD HAVE
LIKED TO HAVE BEEN TREATED WHEN
YOU CAME TO THE UNITED STATES?
>> I WILL TELL YOU SOMETHING, I
FEEL SORRY FOR THESE PEOPLE.
THEY'VE URGE PEOPLE THEY GET
LIED TO, WHEN THE CARTELS LIE
TO THEM.
AND WE ARE ALLOWED TO HAVE
POLICING THE BORDER.
THEY ARE BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF BY CARTELS.
I'M GOING TO MEET WITH THE
AMBASSADOR OF GUATEMALA THIS
WEEK, WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THE
SITUATION.
THESE PEOPLE ARE BECOMING
HOSTAGES.
THEY ARE BECOMING ENSLAVED AND
SOUL TO VERY, VERY DANGEROUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT TAKE CONTROL
OF THE BORDER.
THEY CONTROL THE BORDER.
SO, THESE PEOPLE ARE PONDS.
WITH OUR POLICIES THAT THE
BORDER CREATED, OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE POOR PEOPLE.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, I DO NOT
DISAGREE WITH YOU.
RESPECTFULLY, CONGRESSWOMAN, I
DO NOT DISAGREE WITH YOU AT ALL
ABOUT THE CARTELS TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF MIGRANTS.
IT IS WELL-DOCUMENTED.
I AM WONDERING WHAT YOU THINK
OF WHAT THESE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS HAVE DONE TO THESE
MIGRANTS ONCE THEY HAVE ARRIVED
IN THE UNITED STATES.
APPARENTLY THEY WERE MISLED,
PUT ON PLANES AND BUSES, NOT
KNOWING WHERE THEY WERE GOING.
TOLD THEY WERE GOING TO BE HELD
BY A HUMANITARIAN ORGANIZATION
THAT DOES NOT EXIST.
IS THAT HOW HE WOULD HAVE
WANTED TO BE TREATED WHEN YOU
ARRIVED IN THE UNITED STATES?
AS AN IMMIGRANT?
>> I CAME IN LEGALLY, AND, I
ACTUALLY CAME AND PAID FOR MY
TICKET, AND FOLLOW THE RULES.
AND I CAME TO THE UNITED STATES.
IT WAS A LONG WAY TO BE ABLE TO
FOLLOW THOSE RULES.
SO, I THINK WE NEED TO FIND
LEGAL WAYS FOR PEOPLE TO COME
HERE.
BECAUSE, WHEN YOU CREATE
INCENTIVES TO COME ILLEGALLY,
PEOPLE WILL BE OBVIOUS.
BY THE SYSTEM, I THINK THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE CREATING RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE CREATING INCENTIVES FOR
THESE POOR PEOPLE TO BE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF.
SO, WE NEED TO FIND A GOOD WAY
TO, LEGALLY, FIND PEOPLE
EMIGRATING TO OUR COUNTRY'S
BETTER.
BECAUSE, IT BENEFITS OUR
COUNTRY.
WE ARE A COUNTRY OF IMMIGRANTS.
WE ARE ALSO A COUNTRY OF LAW
AND ORDER.
WE CANNOT HAVE LAWLESSNESS.
I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO DISCUSS.
I AM GLAD WE ARE AT LEAST
TALKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
BECAUSE, WE HAVE A HARD TIME
RAISING AWARENESS.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, AT LEAST MY
DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUES ARE TALKING
ABOUT IT.
AND, THE DEMOCRAT MAYOR OF NEW
YORK IS TALKING ABOUT THAT IT
IS A CRISIS.
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN A CRISIS
FOR A WHILE IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
AND NO ONE WANTS TO LOOK AT
THAT.
AND IT IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
IT IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
AND, I HOPE WE CAN HAVE A
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION.
NOT A POLITICAL ONE.
WE HAVE HUMAN LIVES, WE HAVE
PEOPLE AT STAKE.
WE HAVE A BORDER PATROL AT
STAKE, WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
SO, THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
.
I THINK IT IS NOT TIME FOR
POLITICS.
WE NEED TO FIND SOME SOLUTIONS.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, I HAVE NOT
HEARD YOU GIVE A JUDGMENT ON
WHETHER YOU THINK THESE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS, LIKE RON
DESANTIS AND GREG ABBOTT, AND
DOUG DOOCY, ARE TREATING THESE
MIGRANTS APPROPRIATELY.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THE TACTICS
THAT THEY ARE USING?
>> WELL, YOU HAVE TO LOOK INTO
THAT.
I WAS NOT THERE, I DO NOT KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING.
I AM NOT GOING TO MAKE COMMENTS
ON SOMETHING WHEN I WAS NOT
THERE.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
LOOK INTO THAT.
WHETHER THEY WERE TREATED OR
NOT.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU ONE THING,
RAISING AWARENESS ABOUT THIS
ISSUE BY THESE GOVERNORS, I
APPLAUD THEM FOR DOING THAT.
WE NEED TO RAISE AWARENESS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE,
AS A COUNTRY, START DEALING
WITH THE SITUATION.
YOU KNOW?
HOW IT IS TRADED, HOW IT IS NOT
TREATED, I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK INTO DETAILS.
HOW ENOUGH PEOPLE TO LOOK INTO
THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO COMMENT
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE ONLY
HEARD FROM OTHER PEOPLE.
>> SURE, THERE WILL LIKELY BE
AN INVESTIGATION INTO WHAT IS
MIGRANTS WERE PROMISED.
BUT, SPECIFICALLY, WHAT THESE
GOVERNORS HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED.
RON DESANTIS ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
HE HAD THESE MIGRANTS GET ON A
PLANE TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
HE JOKED ABOUT, IT HE LAUGHED
ABOUT IT WHEN HE WAS TALKING TO
REPORTERS.
IT IS WELL DOCUMENTED WHAT THEY
ARE DOING.
DO YOU AGREE WITH A TACTIC?
DO YOU AGREE WITH WHAT THEY ARE
DOING WITH THESE MIGRANTS?
>> WELL, I THINK, YOU KNOW, IT
IS A PROBLEM OF SOUTHERN
STATES.
THE OTHER STATES NEED TO
UNDERSTAND.
I DO ALSO NOT UNDERSTAND THESE
SANCTUARY CITIES.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
HAVE A POLICY THAT APPLIES TO
ALL OF THESE STATES, THERE ARE
STATES RIGHTS, THERE ARE
FEDERAL RESPONSIBILITIES, AN
IMMIGRATION POLICY IS
CONTROLLED BY THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
SO, I DO NOT THINK CITIES
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CIRCUMVENT
FEDERAL LAWS AND PROVIDE
ILLEGAL PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
STAY IN THE COUNTRY.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS HAPPENING WITH THAT.
AND, I THINK WE HAVE TO START A
DISCUSSION ON THAT.
BUT, I THINK WHAT WAS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW, AND WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE ISSUE, IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT, AND OTHER STATES
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS
NOT JUST A PROBLEM OF TEXAS,
FLORIDA, ARIZONA, CALIFORNIA.
IT IS A PROBLEM FOR ALL OF US.
WE DO NOT HAVE BORDERS FROM
OTHER STATES.
OTHER STATES NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM,
WITH REAL PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU HAVE BORDER PATROL
OVERWHELMED, WHEN YOU HAVE THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN TEXAS WITH
A INFLUX OF ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF
PEOPLE.
THAT IS A PROBLEM!
SO, IT IS A PROBLEM FROM
BIDEN'S VINEYARD, IT IS A
PROBLEM FOR TEXAS.
I THINK THAT MARTHA'S VINEYARD
NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND, THESE
PEOPLE COME WITH BIG NUMBERS.
THEY DO NOT HAVE RESOURCES TO
DEAL WITH THAT EITHER.
WE CANNOT JUST MAKE IT A
PROBLEM OF ONE STATE BECAUSE
THE STATE IS REALLY OVERWHELMED
RIGHT NOW.
IT HAS A HUGE PROBLEM FOR THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
AND, AS YOU KNOW, AS AN INDIANA
REPRESENTATIVE I FEEL I HAVE TO
HELP THE OTHER STATES AS WELL.
IT IS MY DUTY, BECAUSE,
ULTI